revoir l'aj auxerre en ligue 1 guy roux
qu'est ce que ça vous fait aujourd'hui
sa manière je dois dire je suis pas allé
au match que j'ai un peu fatigué mon
coeur avec toutes mes activités on l'a
même un moment mais la sortie on me l'a
mis à 7 degrés on l'a remis dont je fais
attention donc on m'a dit attention pas
d'émotions extraordinaire bon alors un
match comme ça donc j'avais été bien au
match aller parce que je me disais il ya
un match retour de toute façon y aura
pas le résultat non match retour je le
perds je suis pas allé à saint-etienne
et c'est moi j'ai regardé le match
tranquille tout seul et puis avec des
pilules à côté quand même et puis quand
on a marqué de but jusqu'au but 52e
minute j'étais calme aucune accélération
cardiaque et là j'ai mis mes tennis et
je suis parti j'ai fait trois kilomètres
n'ont pas de footing mais de marche je
suis revenu pour les prolongations mais
pourquoi vous aviez peur que ça j'avais
peur de m'exciter trop de me mettre en
danger et alors là quand je suis revenu
j'avais laissé ma télé allumée j'ai vu
que vous préparez les prolongations à
l'est les villes prolongation je
regardais et puis après les penaltys ça
m'a rien fait et alors et là j'avais
confiance et aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que
vous l'allaitez j'avais confiance parce
que j'avais étudié les conditions
psychologiques de l'équipe adverse comme
si j'étais l'entraîneur et j'ai dit si
ici on n'a pas s'ils n'ont pas de 0 ou 3
0 après vous en avoir peur le public
était qui les soutenaient si ils
sentaient en eux mêmes qu'ils allaient
se faire croquer ce qui s'est en fait un
peu produits